This lecture is about the vector space
retrieval model we're going to give a
introduction to its basic idea.
In the last lecture we talked about the
different ways of designing a retrieval
model.
Which would give us a different a
ranking function.
In this lecture we're going to talk
about this specific way of designing
a ranking function
called vector space retrieval
model.
And we're going to give a brief
introduction to the basic idea.
Vector space model is a special case of
similarity based models,
as we discussed before, which means we
assume relevance is roughly
similarity between the document and
the query.
Now, whether this assumption is true is
actually a question.
But in order to solve a search problem,
we have to convert the vague notion of
relevance into a more precise
definition that can be implemented with
the programming language.
So in this process will have to make a
number of assumptions. This is
the first assumption that we make here.
Basically, we assume that if a document
is more similar to a query than
another document
then the first document will be assumed
to be more relevant than the second
one, and this is the basis for ranking
documents in this approach.
Again, it's questionable whether this
is really the best definition for
relevance.
As we will see later, there are other
ways to model relevance.
The basic idea of vector space
retrieval model is actually very easy
to understand.
Imagine a high dimensional space.
Where each dimension corresponds to a
term.
So here I show a 3 dimensional
space.
With three words, programming, library
and presidential.
So each term here defines one
dimension.
Now we can consider vectors in this 3
dimensional space.
And we're going to assume that all our
documents and the query will be placed
in this vector space.
So for example, one document might be
represented by this vector,
D1.
Now this means this document
probably covers library, and
presidential, but it doesn't really
talk about programming.
Alright, what does this
mean terms of representation of
document?
That just means we're going to look at
our document from the perspective of
this vector. We're going to ignore
everything else.
Basically, what we see here is only the
vector representation of the document.
Of course, the document has other
information.
For example, the orders of words are
simply ignored, and that's because we
assume that the bag of words with
representation.
So with this representation you can
already see
D1 seems to suggest a topic
about presidential library.
Now this is different from another
document which might be represented as
a different vector D2 here.
So in this case, the document covers
programming and library, but does not
talk about the presidential.
So what does this remind you?
You can probably guess the topic is
likely about programming language, and
the library is software library.
So this shows that by using this vector
space representation we can actually
capture the differences between topics
of documents.
Now you can also imagine there are other
vectors, for example D3 is
pointing to that direction.
That might be about present in your
program.
And in fact that we can place all the
documents in this vector space.
And they will be pointing to all kinds
of directions.
And similarly, we're going to place our
query also in this space as another
vector.
And then we're going to measure the
similarity between the query vector and
every document vector.
So in this case, for example, we can
easily see D2 seems to be the closest
to this query vector, and therefore
D2 will be ranked above others.
So this is basically the main idea of
the vector space model.
So to be more precise.
To be more precise.
Vector space model is a framework.
In this framework, we make the
following assumptions.
First, we represent a document and
query via term vector.
So here are term can be any basic
concept, for example a word or a
phrase.
Or even N-gram of characters.
Those are just sequence of characters
Inside the word.
Each term is assumed to define one
dimension.
Therefore, N terms in our vocabulary
would define an N dimensional space.
A query vector would consist of a number
of elements.
Corresponding to the weights on
different terms.
Each document vector
is also similar.
It has a number of elements and each
value of each element
is indicating that weight of the
corresponding term.
Here you can see we assume there are N
dimensions.
Therefore there are N elements.
Each corresponding to the weight on a
particular term.
So the relevance in this case would be
assumed to be the similarity between
the two vectors.
Therefore, our ranking function is also
defined as the similarity between the
query vector and document vector.
Now, if I ask you to write a program to
implement this approach in the search
engine,
you would realize that
this is far from clear, right?
We haven't said a lot of things in
detail, therefore it's impossible to
actually write the program to implement
this.
That's why I said this is a framework.
And this has to be refined in order to
actually
suggest a particular ranking function
that you can implement on your
computer.
So what does this framework not say?
It actually hasn't set up many things
that would be required in order to
implement this function.
First, it did not say how we should
define or select the basic concepts
exactly.
We clearly assume the concepts are
orthogonal, otherwise there will be
redundancy.
For example, if two synonyms are
somehow distinguished as two different
concepts, then there would be defining
two different dimensions and that
would clearly cause redundancy here, or
over
emphasizing of matching
this concept.
Because it would be as if you match the
two dimensions when you actually match
one semantic concept.
Secondly, it did not say how exactly
should place documents and query in
this space.
Basically I showed you some examples of
query and document vectors, but where
exactly should the vector for a
particular document point to?
So this is equivalent to how to define
the term weights.
How do you compute those element values
in those vectors?
Now this is a very important question
because
term weight in the query vector indicates
the importance of term.
So depending on how you assign the
weights, you might prefer some terms to
be matched over others.
Similarly to term weight in the document
is also very meaningful. It indicates
how well the term characterizes the
document.
If you got it wrong, then you clearly
don't represent this document
accurately.
Finally, how to define the similarity
measure is also not given.
So these questions must be addressed
before we can have a operational
function that we can actually implement
using a program language.
So how do we solve these problems?
Is the main topic of the next lecture.